There you go.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
for.
So we are picking up where we left off
yesterday morning
and that is the author listing to us the
instances, occasions or times
when it is preferable that a person make
wudoo. One, it is preferable that a
person have wudoo.
Things that a person may do or wish to
do that is preferred that they have
wudoo when they do them. The first thing
that he mentioned was a very general
thing and that is any remembrance of
Allah.
The second thing that he mentioned is
sleep. Any kind of sleep. Anytime a
person goes to sleep.
There's a book that
Kayim wrote. it's probably one of his
most
famous, well-known, most influential
books of everything that he's written.
And he's written a lot. He has over a
hundred different titles.
And in this book, he named the book
It's called the path to the two
migrations.
And it's a very captivating title
because you think to yourself,
what what are the two migrations? Well,
the entire premise of the title and the
book is explaining that none of us will
find salvation in the hereafter,
nor comfort and
solace in the dunya
without
making hij
toahillahill
and h to Muhammad Allah. We have to
that this is the way that a person is to
make the
metaphorical hijra
the metaphorical hijra to Allah and to
his messenger sallall.aii wasallam.
And then he he calls it and the key to
the two happinesses meaning the
happiness of this life and the happiness
of the next life. The happiness the ja
of this dunya and the jenna of the
hereafter. And this is a play on one
of the statements that Islam made one of
his teachers. He said
They said that this dunya here that we
live on, it has a jenna in it. And if
you fail to enter the jenna of this
dunya, you will not be allowed to enter
the jenna of the hereafter.
And he's referring to the statement of
Allah.
And that is the ja of closeness and the
worship of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
The jah of finding solace.
Finding solace right in the remembrance
of Allah in the worship and obedience of
Allah. And so this book you might think
what does this have to do with woo?
I'm telling you this about the book
because it's good for you to read it.
But he has a chapter in this book where
he explains the sunnah
of making wuboo
when we go to sleep and why it is the
sunnah to make woo before you sleep.
He says that when a person sleeps, Allah
has told us that Allah
takes the souls when people sleep
because sleep is a type of death. It's
not death but it is akin to death and it
is a partial death and it is a minor
death as the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam said. Abu Mus Ali tells us that
a man asked the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam.
He said
[Silence]
Abu Mus says that a man asked the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam.
Oh messenger of Allah, do the people in
paradise sleep?
Do they take naps? Do they sleep? He
said sleep
is the brother of death.
It is the cousin of death. It is akin to
death.
And the people of paradise do not die in
any way.
There's no time for sleep in paradise.
There's no sleeping, right?
And so Allah tells us in
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala he is the
one who retrieves the souls of those who
die and those who do not die in their
sleep. Listen to the wording. He
retrieves the souls of those who die and
those who do not die in their sleep.
Meaning when we sleep, it is a partial
death. It is a minor death. It is a
microcosm of death. It is a simulation
of death. It is a partial retrieval of
the soul. Now where does the soul go
when it goes to sleep? We don't know.
Allah there's nothing clearly mentioned
in the Quran and Sunnah
very specific
however we know that Allah takes these
souls where he puts them
Allah but he subhanahu wa ta'ala he
takes these souls he retrieves them when
people sleep when a human being sleeps
and so
says that the believer
Woo is not just for the body. Woo
is a purification of the soul. It's a
spiritual purification.
We don't know how it affects the spirit
exactly the mechanics of it. But it is a
spiritual purification
because when a person does not have
water or cannot use water, what do they
do?
to make. What is this? Is
what does that do? Tell me what does
that do? What does that change? Or as
they say, what does that change with
respect to the price of tea in China?
Doesn't actively change anything that we
can see, but it has a very profound
effect on the soul.
And this is why the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam tells us that on the day of
judgment when the soul is primary and
the body reflects what is going on in
the soul. In the dunya it's the
opposite. The body is primary and what
happens to the body reflects itself on
the soul. In the hereafter it's exactly
the opposite.
The soul is primary and the body is
secondary.
And the body reflects what is happening
with the soul.
So in the hereafter the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam says
when he was asked by his companions how
do you know how are you going to
recognize your nation? There's a lot of
them. There's a lot of other nations on
the day of judgment. How are you going
to recognize us or those of us whom you
have not met? And he said that my
will come on the day of judgmental
in in in the Arabic language
are horses that have white on their
foreheads
and is white
feet. Right? So he's saying just like
horses
have white feet and white foreheads
that the Muslim on the day of judgment
will come and the place where he made
wudoo will be light
will be all light. The face,
the arms,
the head, the ears, the feet will be
light, be white.
And so
when Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala takes the
soul, the soul goes back to Allah in a
state of wudoo in sleep.
You go back to Allah in a state of
wudoo.
So one of the reasons that tells us in
he says the reason that the prophet Sam
was made wudoo
before sleeping and encouraged and
commanded and highly
emphasized making wudoo before
sleeping is so that the believer's soul
when Allah takes it at sleep he takes it
in a state of purity
so that when Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
wishes to show the believer of wisdom in
his sleep or you know it's it's
making it's a it's a form of a person
making preparing himself to be taken by
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. So this is
why we make wudoo before we sleep or one
of the reasons why we make wudoo before
we sleep. The prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam would always make wudoo before
he goes to sleep. And if he didn't have
water or was unable to use it or was
too tired to use it or the he
would at least make
if he's in a state of janaba before he
goes to sleep
as we will hear in those chapters.
Foreham.
[Silence]
Alhamdulill.